[موسيقى]
مرحبا شكرا كتير على حضوركم انا ما سمعت
بالضبط شو الاجوبه اللي جاوبتوها اذا
حضرتوا افلام او لا بس يعني بتمنى انكم
تحضروا افلام لانه الافلام
انا هلا موجود هون عشان حاب اجاوب على
السؤال او اساعد الجميع هون انه يقدر
يجاوب سؤال لو اجى حدا مثلا
ابنك او بنتك مثلا
وقال انا بدي ادرس في الميكينج او بدي
اشتغل بالفيلم شو جوابنا راح يكون وهذا
طبعا بيضوء الكلام اللي عم نسمعه عن
التطورات اللي قاعده عم بتصير فراح احاول
شوي انه يعني نوضح الصوره شوي نحكي عن
المستقبل السينما
يعني عشان نقدر نوصل فكره اوضاع هلا
اول شيء احنا بنعرف انه مستقبل انه
السينما صناعه السينما بشكل عام هي صناعه
ضخمه
وفي دول بتستفيد منها بشكل كتير كبير
من ناحيه اقتصاديه
وفي دول كمان عم بتحاول تستفيد منها شوي
شوي اكثر ومن هاي الدول الاردن
وهذا ما كان ممكن يصير الا مع الانفتاح
العالمي للاسواق فاحنا مثلا
صرنا نسمع عن افلام هوليود
مثل هون انه قدرت تصير تعرض بالصين على
سبيل المثال اللي هو اكبر
يسوق بالعالم فصرنا نسمع عن افلام عن
ايرادات الافلام عم تتجاوز حاجز الاثنين
مليار دولار من ناحيه الدخل وهدول الاربعه
افلام على سبيل المثال يعني بس من
2015-2023
وهاي ارقام يعني بس جديد عم نسمع عنها
احنا
ومن الامثله كمان على انفتاح السوق كمان
مسلسل مدرسه الروابي للبنات المسلسل
الاردني اللي انعرض على
منصه نتفليكس هلا الغريب انه هذا المسلسل
كان من ضمن
بقاره جنوب امريكا
فيعني شوي هذا يعني برضه غريب هلا
الفتره اللي فاتت احنا عم يعني عم نحكي من
العشرين سنه اللي فاتت عم نبلش نحس انه في
زي سمات العالم جديد لعصر جديد قاعد عم
بتتكون
وهذا العالم يعني من سماته خلينا نحكي
السياسيه انه صار في تعدد للاقطاب وانفصال
للاسواق هذا من ناحيه ومن ناحيه تكنولوجيه
طبعا زملائي المختصين بتكنولوجيا اكيد
تغطي الموضوع بطريقه كتير ادق مني يعني بس
صار في عنا تطور سريع جدا للتكنولوجيا من
ناحيه ال 5 جي من ناحيه الاي اي والانترنت
فمن المتوقع انه خلال الثلاث سنوات
القادمه انه يكون في اكثر من 64
مليار جهاز موصول على الانترنت
فيعني خلينا بس هيك نحاول نتخيل انه كيف
ممكن الاي اي يستفيد من كميه المهوله هاي
للدات
وانا من يعني زي معظم هون اكيد سمعت عن
متجرني اللي اعلنوا عنه جديد وحبيت يعني
ما افوت اجرب هذا الموقع
فدخلت على متجرني بدي لو سمحت
صوره او خلينا نحكي رسمه للبتره بس باسلوب
فانجوخ بس هيك وما شرحت اي اشي تاني
فاعطاني هاي الصوره طبعا على طول هيك هلا
بنقدر نشوف احنا باللوحه هاي
يعني اذا بندقق فيها شوي وانا هيك برضو
بلشت اسال حالي يعني انه على اي اساس
اختار هاي الرسمه تحديدا
تذكرت انه في زاويه معينه دائما في بنلاقي
صور كتير للبتره فيها يعني
الها من هاي الزاويه هاي من ناحيه وطبعا
في تبعت اللي من جوا السيق اذا متذكرينها
وفي كمان شغله ثانيه انه انا لما كتبت
البتراء احنا بنعرف ان البتراء هي مدينه
هي مش بس الخزنه بينما هو على طول اعطاني
الخزنه هاي من ناحيه ومن ناحيه تانيه كمان
كانت اللوحه اللي اعتمد عليها برسم السماء
والالوان والخطوط
والامر او نجوم او هيك هي اللوحه من لوحه
من اخر مسيره فانغو الفنيه اللي هي
ستارينايت واللي هي وحده من اكثر اللوحاته
شهره كمان
فهذا من ناحيه من ناحيه من ناحيه تاني
برضو رحت على
بدي اجرب
طبعا بنعرف احنا انه من فتره قريبه يعني
بس الاسبوع اللي فات اعلنوا عن الجيل
الرابع فانا دخلت على
وطلبت انه يكتب لي سيناريو فيلم قصير مدته
خمس دقائق بس
من غير اي تردد بلش
يكتب لي انه اه طبعا وبلش يحكي لي شو هي
القصه
من الوهله الاولى شفت انا انه كتير يعني
شكل السيناريو اللي مكتوب بس لما بلشت
اقرا القصه يعني ما بعرف بحب اني احكي لكم
اياها شوي القصه نفسها تبعت السيناريو
معلش سوري انا شكلي شارب قهوه كتير
القصه باختصار
بنت قاعده عم تلعب تلفونها بكوفي شوب
بتخلص بطاريه تلفونها فبتصير تطلع حواليها
بتلاقي شب هذا الشاب مع كتب فبتروح عنده
بتستاذنه بتقول له ممكن لو سمحت بس اخذ
كتاب لانه تليفوني فضيت بطاريته بيعطيها
الكتاب فهي بترجع بتقعد بتقرا الكتاب كامل
فبترجع للشاب بتقول له شكرا وبتتوتر كثير
وبتهرب برا الكوفي شوب
بيجي بلحقها الشاب وبرضو بركض وراها بر
الكوفي شوب بقولها لحظه لحظه
وبتوقف هي بتقول له ايش في بقولها انا
حبيت ابتسامتك
هذا هو الفيلم
[موسيقى]
نشاط الدماغ والاعصاب تبعنا واحنا قاعدين
عم نحضر فيلم معين او مقطع من فيلم معين
فهاي كلياتها يعني بتولد حجم للداتا يعني
كبير
هلا احنا قبل ما يعني اقدر اني اتوقع شو
المستقبل او احكي لكم شو المستقبل بحب اني
اعطيكم قصتين سريعات من
الماضي او التاريخ تبع السينما هلا
السينما عمرها بهاي السنه عم نحكي بحدود
ال127 سنه اللي هو اشي يعني اكتشاف جديد
نسبيا وبنعرف احنا انه ببدايات السينما
حاط برضه صوره الزميل تشارلي تشابلن اكيد
كنا بنعرفه
كان من مرحله السينما الصامته
هاي السينما الصامته ضلت من عم نحكي من
سنه 1894
تقريبا او خمسين
لا فتره يعني عم نحكي عن تقريبا
32 سنه
كان
قاعات العرض اللي بتشبه هاي يعني او
مختلفه كان يكون في عازف بيانو بيقعد يعزف
موسيقى تصويريه لايف والفيلم ولا اي صوت
له يعني ما عم نسمع ولا اي اشي عنه واكيد
شفته يعني
طبعا صلاه السينما الشعبيه بالصلاه
السينما يعني ارقى شوي بكون في اوركسترا
كامله
وموسيقيين يعني عم بعزفوا الموسيقى
التصويريه هلا كان في محاولات كتير
لاكتشاف
الطريقه لتسجيل الصوت
وما رح احكي انه اخترع هو سجل براءه
اختراع توماس اديسون لاختراع بسجل الصوت
اختراع تاني
بسجل على الفيلم يعني بسجل الصوره خلينا
نحكي المتحركه وبرجع بعرضها للشخص بس
لشخص واحد يعني خلينا نحكي
هلا ضل هذا
الشكل السينما لفتره بنحكي احنا 32 سنه
وكان في علماء يعني فعلا قدروا يلاقوا
طريقه جديده انه تتسجل يتسجل الفيديو او
الفيلم الصور المتحركه تتسجل
ويتسجل الصوت معها وينعرضوا مع بعض هذا
طبعا بعد محاولات كثيره يعني بحب اني اعرض
لكم اولها هو فيديو طوله 16 ثانيه بس هذا
اول فيديو بالتاريخ لا صوت وصوره متزامنين
من سنه 1894
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
يعني
من الواضح انه
ما كانوا هم عارفين انه هذا الفيديو فعليا
راح يدخل التاريخ
ونصفي هلا بس برضو غريب انه نقدر نسمع صوت
حدا عم بعزف من قبل 127 سنه ونشوف شابين
عم برسوا مع بعض
هذا هاي كانت البدايات تبعت السينما وما
حدا كان عارف انه هاي صناعه راح تكون كتير
كبيره
ورح يعني تجاوز 100 مليار دولار بحجم قطاع
هلا زي ما حكينا احنا انه في علماء معينين
لقوا طريقه لتسجيل الصوت والصوره وعرضها
بشكل متزامن مع بعض وكان يروحوا
للاستديوهات الكبيره اللي كانت معروفه
وقتها
وكانوا يعرض عليهم هذا يعرض عليهم هذا
الاكتشاف الجديد وكانوا هدول الاستديوهات
يرفضوا رفض تام للفكره لانه ببساطه الامور
ماشيه ومستوره يعني
عم بعملوا افلام والناس بيجوا بحضروا ت
ممتاز يعني بس اجا استوديو صغير
وقرر انه يتبنى هاي التكنولوجيا الجديده
وعمل اول فيلم
ناطق بالسينما بسموه اسمه دجاج واسم هذا
الاستوديو
وانشهر الاستوديو كتير سنه 1927 لما اصدر
هذا الفيلم
لدرجه انه بخلال سنتين بس من صدور هذا
الفيلم
صار فيه 75% من الافلام المنتجه وبالعالم
كله كمان فصار الاشي طبيعي انه يكون في
صوت على الفيديو هاي الفكره من هاي القصه
انه نبين كيف السينما بتقدر تستوعب
تكنولوجيا جديده
وتصير جزء يعني جزء منها يعني وتتبناها
فعليا
القصه الثانيه اللي بحكي لكم اياها كمان
هي عن قصه انتشار التلفزيون
بفتره الستينات تحديدا هلا التلفزيون تم
اختراعه بفتره قبل بس صار
منتشر كتير بالبيوت يعني كلياتها بفتره
الستينات عم نحكي بامريكا ومناطق ثانيه
كمان بالعالم فكانت السينما
عم بيبين عندها كتير انه في هبوط بعدد
التذاكر اللي عم تنباع الناس بحضروا بدل
ما يجوا على السينما
فيعني اتوتروا شوي وصاروا
يحاولوا قد ما يقدروا
يضيفوا على الابهار
البصري يعني على الفيلم ويحاولوا يوصل
لاكتشافات جديده فمثلا هون احنا عم نشوف
انه توصلوا لل 3d مثلا كان في تسجيل وعرض
للتريدي وفعلا زي ما احنا شايفين كانوا
يحضروا بنظارات ما كان في اقبال كتير على
هاي تكنولوجيا وقتها وكانت لسه بداياتها
وكان في كمان تكنولوجيات تانيه كمان زي
اوديو وغيرها بس عشان يقدروا يجذبوا الناس
للسينما قاعد سينما كمان مره يعني في فيلم
فيلم
كليوباترا مثلا كان يجيبوا الاف من
المجاميع يعني جيوش دول فعليا تيجي عشان
نشوف احنا على
جوا الفيلم بنشوف اعداد مهوله للناس اللي
واقفين وجزء من الفيلم وفي فيلم في فيلم
اللي تصور عنا هون بالاردن بالمناسبه
هذا كله كان محاولات زي ما بنحكي لجذب
الناس لقاعات سينما بينما التلفزيون برضه
من ناحيته كان برضه قلم بتطور صار في
برامج مخصصه للتلفزيون بتنعم فعوده الى
السؤال الاول اللي كنا بنحكي عنه انه هل
يعني انا شخصيا بنصح حد انه
حد جديد انه يدخل مجال صناعه الافلام
ويتعلم
ويكرس كل حياته الها اكيد طبعا ومش بس
صناعه الافلام اي عمل تاني فيه ابداع
وابتكار لانه طول ما في ابتكار وابداع راح
يضل في مجال
انه الاي اي يكون موجود كمساعد لنا واحنا
نضلنا عاملين شغلنا ومنطور من حالنا بشكل
كتير كبير وشكرا كتير
[تصفيق]